[Music]
number one Brendan Fraser is friends
with The Rock correct
but they never actually met while
filming The Mummy Returns also correct
he was a piece of tape on a stick a lot
easier to fight in that way
room two Brendan wore prosthetics for
his role in the whale also correct
people mistake Brendan Fraser and Nathan
Fillion often it happens at Fan
convention sometimes he takes my booth
and I take his
Brendan Fraser is Sadie sink's dad in
movie world
mercedesync's dad is a football coach
and he has a handshake like a stone
Mason you'll want that guy on your side
I'm teaming up with the rock for a new
Mummy film oh uh stay tuned I don't know
that one either
Brendan is being removed from The Mummy
ride incorrect
I think we just got new light bulbs put
in